[Musique]
on pourrait croire qu'il est facile
d'oublier des noms comme celui de Portia
White et pourtant le timbre de cette
voix particulière a ouvert la voie à
toute une génération première chanteuse
noire de concert au Canada à être
acclamé sur la scène internationale la
néo écossaise trait son chemin dans les
années 40 malgré l'ampleur de la
discrimination raciale
considérée comme l'une des plus grandes
voies de la musique classique du 20e
siècle pour siawa est à briller de mille
feux à plus de 100 concerts dont un
privé pour la reine Elizabeth II
[Musique]
et d'autres après elles ont aussi brisé
des plafonds de verre comme cet homme
Lincoln Alexander le Premier ministre
brendoline en effet annoncé la
nomination de lenken à l'extender comme
représentant de la reine en Ontario
premier noir à devenir député au Canada
ministre de cabinet et lieutenant
gouverneur de l'Ontario lincol Alexender
c'est longtemps battu pour l'égalité
raciale une lutte acharnée qui lui a
valu en 2015 que l'on désigne le 21
janvier jour de sa naissance comme une
journée célébrée en son honneur au
Canada
et on pourrait penser que cette autre
héroïne s'est inspiré de lui
puisqu'en 1993 d'inaugustine devient la
première femme noire être élue à la
Chambre des communes la première est
nommée dans un cabinet ministériel au
Canada en 2002
pour devenir par la suite ministre des
terres responsable du multiculturalisme
et de la situation de la femme
que nous devons en 1995 la proclamation
du mois de février comme celui de
l'histoire des Noirs au Canada
Willy Ory voici un autre bâtisseur
premier joueur noir affoulé la glace de
la Ligue nationale de hockey en 1958 la
star de Frédéric Town members de Boston
affrontait ce jour-là les Canadiens de
Montréal
qui venait avec son lot de solitude
puisque seul noir de sa génération dans
ce sport l'athlète a longtemps des
victimes de racisme Willy hurry a été
intronisée au Temple de la renommée de
hockey en 2018
il se souvient
ient du jazz montréalé Charlie bidoll et
fatigable promoteur de ce genre musical
l'artiste inspiré tout le Québec par son
engagement auprès des jeunes artistes de
toutes les communautés en 1979 le
contrebassiste organise un festival de
jazz considéré par plusieurs comme le
précurseur du Festival International de
Jazz de Montréal en 1981 il ouvre son
club au centre ville de Montréal le
Beatles jazz and ribs endroit phare et
ont servi de tremplin pour la carrière
de nombreux musiciens Charlie bidol a
été nommé membre de l'or du Canada en
si ces icônes ont marqué leur temps
celui dont l'oeuvre reste fraîche dans
les cœurs c'est Karim Wallet le plus
doux renard comme on le surnomme avec
une feuille de route impressionnante 8
Félix à son actif un jumeau pour l'album
francophone de l'année en 2014 et 2017
l'auteur compositeur interprète à
notamment été nommé Révélations
Radio-Canada en 2012-2013
à travers le temps c'est bâtisseurs ont
ouvert la voie au futur générations et
leur héritage sur à ton sorte qu'on ne
les oubliera jamais ici Daniel Kadjo
Radio-Canada Montréal